this CCTV of Eleanor Williams buying a
hammer in Tesco would be used in court
to prosecute her police say it's what
she used to injure herself in an effort
to support lies that she'd been raped
and battered by multiple men now Miss
Williams has been sentenced to eight and
a half years in jail for perverting the
course of Justice
there is no explanation for why the
defendant would commit these offenses
she has gone to extraordinary lengths to
create false accusations including
causing herself significant injury
outside Court men she'd falsely accused
spoke of the impact of her crimes I've
had my landlord call me a rapist I've
had people across the road called me a
rapist I've had neighbors call me a
rapist you know just mod sticks like
everyone looks at you everyone knows who
you are you know what I mean like
because I was named in the paper for a
such serious sexual offense what I
didn't do the way we were targeted as a
community and then we were as in the
community of borough then we were like
picked out so persecution it's a sense
of persecution that don't play it in the
21st century and it was just we're going
for the Asians and it was a full-on
targeted or towards the agents Elena
Williams claims about an alleged Asian
grooming gang which she posted on
Facebook changed the peaceful Seaside
town of barrel
although some of the men she alleged
draped her were white the small Asian
Community were harassed and spat at
windows were smashed
[Music]
amid protests erupting in Town Police
couldn't yet reveal they had evidence
she was lying
for example this footage of her checking
into a hotel in Blackpool on her own at
a time she claimed she was being raped
in a number of different properties
there's a number of victims in this case
men who've been arrested subjected to
intimate examinations some held in
custody for periods of time and then
there's all the wider Community issues
and tensions resulting from this case
I've never seen anybody I've had cases
where people have told lies but never
ever to this extent and I do believe
that if she hadn't been charged
in this instance it just wouldn't have
stopped Miss Williams was found to have
set up numerous fake social media
accounts to message herself to make it
appear that she was receiving messages
from abusers speaking for the first time
Eleanor's sister Lucy says that
sometimes her sister did Doctor things
on her phone but says she filmed
threatening texts as they came through
including a video of a gun and pictures
of machetes and says she witnessed
intimidation first hand one of the men
was harassing Ellie at the bar
um and some of our friends seen it and
they'd warned him off it grabbed her
outside of the takeaway started pulling
her around he was like come on we're
going to see that yeah you say you saw
someone grab her yeah and she was like
no I'm going with my sister and his face
he was so angry with her and and she did
come home with me and then the next
weekend she came back black and blue
like worse than we'd ever seen
Lucy believes this was a different man
not named as a victim in the case it was
Lucy who took the photos of the injuries
that Eleanor posted on Facebook that a
pathologist would later say in court
were consistent with being
self-inflicted but Lucy doesn't accept
that
do you think there's any chance
theoretically that on that occasion she
hurt herself no in order to create more
impact no
that on that occasion
that one time she couldn't have done it
to herself I don't believe so or no very
few other people have seen those
injuries first hand yeah you have yeah
you were there
just describe them I've never seen
anything like it obviously I've worked
in nursing homes and I've seen some
awful stuff but nothing like what I've
seen on Ellie
police say they've investigated every
claim and found no evidence of abuse
she would regularly present at work at
home with bruises and other injuries do
you think they were all self-inflicted
but certainly be evidence points to it
was there any other because I mean when
the defense made the point that only
that the images from May 2020 were
examined by a pathologist why were the
other other bruises not examined well in
a lot of the cases with the other
bruising it was very difficult in time
to say when when it occurred you know we
didn't have um you know proper police
photographs of a lot of those injuries
and so it was decided to focus on the
injuries in May 2020 did you have police
photographs of the injuries in May 2020
uh we didn't but we had some good um
good photographs of them but we were
taken by her sister yeah but we were
able to present to the expert so as the
pictures taken by her sister not police
photographs that the pathologist made
the conclusion on yeah I mean if you in
court you'd have seen which photographs
were used
Eleanor's family except she lied about
things such as claims that she was
trafficked abroad but for her mother
Alison it doesn't make the verdict any
less painful
and how did you feel when that guilty
verdict came through how broken were you
there were you in the court
just describe it to me I can't
can't still
can't take it now really
it just doesn't feel real
the person that the Press are betraying
is not the person I know
what do you think her motives were for
for making up the things that she she
did makeup I just believed that she was
trying to get people to listen to her
in a statement reading Court Miss
Williams says she was sorry for mistakes
she'd made but she didn't admit guilt
the men who faced false allegations say
that is a hollow apology
Jason Farrell Sky News